in testing times come opportunities for
dan parsons a founding partner at the
uk's largest electric bike business the
shadow cast by the pandemic was a chance
to get people out of their vehicles and
try a greener more cost-effective way of
getting around
it paid off but what's happened is
demand has gone up enormously for
alternative means of transport like the
electric bike and supply has just fallen
through the floor our costs as a
business have grown enormously as well
you know we've seen rent increases
and there are costs associated with that
across the country businesses are
feeling the pressure in 2020 shoe
designer cat mcconey overcame financial
challenges by focusing on e-commerce but
now her business has to navigate those
soaring shipping costs affecting global
trade
we're looking at about 35 to 40 in some
cases on last year's costs
um which you know really significantly
eats into our margin um so we're
actually bringing all our stock in from
china at the moment but we're actually
looking to move some of our
manufacturing to spain to sort of
eliminate some of that extra shipping
cost while businesses are seeing huge
increases in the cost of materials many
of those that can't afford to absorb
those costs are having to pass them on
to the consumers have less cash to spare
and with many of them also having to
make serious choices about what they
need to cut back on such as food or fuel
as energy costs rise so to have food
prices pushing inflation up to a 40-year
high with the bank of england predicting
it will get worse before the end of the
year people are already working hard
people already have jobs they still
can't find a way to make ends meet and
that's where we are before these energy
prices started to increase you know the
problem inside the uk economy over a
much longer period of time has actually
been that people have been doing the
right thing
but unable to pay the bills with a cost
of living outstripping wage growth in
the uk there is already enormous
pressure on households but as the summer
turns to autumn further challenges await
the bank of england predicts inflation
will increase before the end of the year
just when the cap on fuel prices is set
to increase seeing a massive rise in
energy bills
leaving many fearing a winter of
discontent
and a government faced with difficult
decisions on how to deal with the
oncoming storm sony gallego al jazeera
london